welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast i'm your
host hisham azuz and this is another
installment of the early on in
recruitment podcast series where we're
sitting down with recruiters who are
early on in their career to find out
what have been some of their biggest
challenges how they overcame them what
advice do they have for people starting
out in their careers
and uh much more i'm delighted to be
joined by hannah vine today and we're
gonna sort of unpack her journey she's
been working in recruitment for 14 16
months and uh
yeah we're gonna we're gonna dive
straight in so hannah thanks for for
joining me
thanks for having me i'm excited
so i think where i've been starting with
people
is uh sort of where peop what people's
expectations were and sort of
what actually transpired so i guess
let's just start sort of from what i can
obviously this is your this has been
your first recruitment job right
yeah
so um yeah let's just start with like
how has recruitment been compared to
what hannah expected going into this
journey
yeah so i guess in the long term i never
really knew what recruitment was it was
only kind of throughout uni where i
started hearing about people who you
know went into recruitment and you know
knowing that it was an actual job um
but i'd say like the funniest thing is i
basically got the job
my first recruitment job in october time
and then because of kobe do went into
another lockdown my start date got
pushed back from october back to
february and in that time in that period
of time i was having an absolute freak
out like i was like i don't know
anything about recruitment i don't know
anything about technology i nearly
pulled out so many times i nearly like
retracted like i was like i don't like i
don't know anything at all i was
terrified i had this perception that i
need to already be an expert i was
watching youtube videos like like every
day and i was just so nervous but i
literally started and i was like oh
there's nothing to be scared about
nothing to be worried about you don't
need to have experience in recruitment
or anything like that you don't need to
know anything about technology you will
literally be trained from day one on
what you need to do so i think over
complicating it in your head is like the
worst thing to do because it's abs like
there's
no expectation there for you to know
stuff already so i think i worked myself
up a little bit too much about it but
yeah in reality i think recruitment you
get taught everything you need to know
that's one of the main things i can like
tell people i guess from who are you
know getting into like maybe worried
about it yeah sure yeah
so how did you go about you mentioned
the the industry there a lot of people
that i speak to that early on sometimes
get sort of caught up in that i don't
know if you've been on a journey with
this but like can oftentimes lack
confidence because they feel like they
have to know as much as the people
they're speaking to or sometimes doubt
or sort of say things like
why would they speak to me when i've
only got three months experience so how
have you gone about then sort of as you
said you there obviously the tom and the
team have obviously helped you and
trained you up but like how have you
gone about acquiring the knowledge
of your sector and those things how have
you gone about that
i'd say the first thing is and the thing
that will get ingrained into you
throughout recruitment and the start of
your career is like get on the phones
and literally on the phone the people
speak to people that's the only way
you're gonna learn like even if you have
no idea what they're talking about the
more you hear the same words the way
they're phrased all that sort of thing
that will you know you'll start picking
it up there's no point pushing it away
or like doubting yourself about it and
people say fake it till you make it
that's basically like
if you pretend you know what you're
talking about you're gonna sound like
you know what you're talking about like
if you sound confident while you're
saying it
like i think the worst thing you can do
is shy away from it and you know
worry that you don't actually know what
you're talking about there's so many
like resources out there as well like
speaking to people on linkedin and
things like that where you can pretty
much learn whatever market you're in and
i think the easiest thing to do is
obviously focus on one specific market
or area and put as much time as you can
into that and ensure that
you know you're actually channeling
everything into one area because you'll
pick up a lot quicker and then
you will sound a lot more knowledgeable
i guess if you're trying to learn like
multiple different markets all at once
it's going to take you
like if you're trying to learn four
markers it's going to take you four
times as long to become an expert in
them all so if you learn one conquer
that you're going to pick up knowledge
about other areas on the way as well so
yeah just focus on obviously the area
that you're
you're kind of working in and don't
don't stress too much
like fake it don't you make it
so
with that i think just what would be
useful hannah on that if you don't mind
sharing is
like when you when you did speak to
people maybe even still now like do you
do you own the fact that oh you know
what that's really interesting to say
that i haven't sort of heard that before
could you tell me more about that
because i think that's sometimes what
people miss or understand is that
actually people really enjoy speaking
about themselves and if you actually
have the humility to go you know what
actually i don't actually know much
about that or that's the first time
someone said that could you tell me a
bit more like how how did you actually i
know you said fake it till you make it
i'd totally get that and sort of leading
with confidence but when there was parts
where like yeah these people were
talking about things that you had no
[ __ ] clue about did you sort of own
it and sort of be like that's really
interesting tell me more about that i'm
still learning in this space i don't
know how did you own that and talk about
that and how does that resonate with
people
yeah i think that humility aspect of it
is you know super important and at the
end of the day people are like
everyone's human
you're not like even people who work in
that space aren't an expert on it they
don't know everything about it and it's
funny you say that literally this week
i've been working in some roles in a
completely new domain and i literally
like sent out and i've been calling
people and saying honestly like i'm
reaching out to you i can tell you the
basics but i'm going to put this on you
to actually tell me some information
about it because this isn't my core
market if i'm like holding my hands up i
don't actually know
much about the area and i sent out like
a linkedin message that was you know
saying a similar thing um like you know
i've got these roles it's not my core
market i don't know too much about it um
you know would you be interested in the
role or even if you're not interested in
the role would you be
like if you can tell me any information
about this space where you've got any
like advice or help and so many people
came back to that and they were so nice
they were like i'm not looking for a new
role at the moment but i'm really happy
to have a chat with you about the area
and so yeah it's just like
remembering that they're human like
people are like people want to help each
other and again once someone is an
expert in that area they want to speak
about it like they've got all that
knowledge there and again
yeah
they're lean on that like especially i
guess that in the techie space people
they've got a lot of experience and
they've got a lot of skills and they
want to show that off and they want you
to know they know what they're talking
about so yeah 100 people that they like
that humanity aspect of it
yeah it's a great insight thanks for
sharing that and yeah really interesting
new experience at this week but that's a
great insight and definitely if you
listen to this take that approach and
yeah what a great position to be in that
you've got people in your market willing
to talk to you and uh yeah then like
there's so much information you could
take from that and and yeah that's
that's awesome so i guess what what
skills or experiences recruitment giving
you then that you least expected
so far
i think one of the main things is
i don't know how best to phrase it like
not caring about things as much
like i think in the start you take
things to heart a lot and you think oh
it's the end of the world but now it's i
think
in the professional side of it in
recruitment as well as in my personal
life like you don't take things so
seriously like it's really not that deep
like
it's something like something small
happens when you when you start working
there you're like oh no no it's the end
of the world and but you look back and
you're like oh why did why why did i
care so much like no one died like
everyone's fine like there's no point
stressing over little things and i think
it's really helped me to realize like
you put things into perspective i think
i think that's one of the main things
that i've learned is it's really not
that bad
like what's the worst that could happen
i think that's like really important to
keep in mind um
that yeah i'd say that's one of the big
things
that's such a superpower that for sure
like
yeah like that can help you in a lot of
scenarios in work and outside of work
when you're yeah
oh sorry not just to say it's not
something that's like easy to learn you
can't really learn it without
like going through something to learn it
you can't just like read a book and then
suddenly start thinking differently i
think you've got to experience and like
build up that tolerance to it i guess
like tolerance yeah
happening a lot of yeah no i yeah but
yeah it definitely in today's in today's
uh day and age like it does it does
worry me that people
like literally could potentially have
their days ruined if like someone cut
them in the traffic or like the
starbucks person spelled their name
wrong on their sort of starbucks cup or
whatever like that yeah i think a lot of
people get triggered so easily i do
still have bad road rage but
yeah i think i think that's a really
cool insight actually that yeah it's
actually helped you just be able to be
like instead of fretting and maybe
losing a lot of energy and and losing uh
yeah sleepless nights over things or
worrying about things you've sort of got
that muscle now of like actually you
know what let's move on let's pick
myself back up and crap
one of our favorite phrases here is we
go again something bad happens
again like what is the point of dwelling
on things literally no point
yeah no great attitude so so on the on
that then what
what what has been your biggest
challenge so far on this journey like
most people i'm sure you might have
heard this in the office you might even
have it said to you that yeah first-year
recruitment can be [ __ ] difficult
maybe the most probably the most
difficult in your journey
so
sort of looking back obviously your past
this year mark now so like what would
you say were the biggest challenges the
biggest stumbling blocks that you had to
sort of work through in those first 12
months
it's quite funny because now i look back
it's really hard to pinpoint like
i feel like in the moment you think it's
the end of the world and you're like oh
this is so bad
but then a few months later you're like
what even what was it what was like what
was the low what was i upset about what
um
but
my favorite cliche i'm sure you've
probably heard this 100 times this week
already recruitment is a roller coaster
it literally is ups and downs like
every person who joins i always tell
them like you're going to have your
worst day ever
and you're going to want to quit like at
the start this is so prevalent for me it
was one day i hated it i came home and i
was like i'm going to quit i'm going to
quit and then the next day i literally
had the best day ever and i was like i
love this job this is amazing
and like it evens out like it slows down
and you don't get like that as much like
at towards like the year mark or so but
at the start that was happening like
literally every day um and it was funny
because i that's my one piece of advice
that i tell everyone who joins is like
you're gonna have your worst day ever
that's a pivotal point if you come back
in the next day you're gonna have your
best day ever but if you like listen to
that and you're like oh i had a bad day
i am gonna quit like you're not gonna
have the opportunity to have that that
good day that you know eggs you want um
so
yeah no i i think um
it's wider than that then just sort of
riding the roller coaster
so what are you talking about here then
so a lot a lot of people ask me or
wanted me to ask this so what you're
talking about here probably people were
calling resilience
and like wanting to push on and wanting
to dust yourself off and come back in
again
so like how so clearly you've done
clearly you've cultivated that clearly
you've worked on that muscle of
resilience because as you just said
there multiple times in that first year
you went home you wanted to quit uh so
and you didn't so why like like how did
you push through that what were the
things was it just this year ability to
go right that was like not what more bad
can happen i'm gonna carry on
like how did you push with that how did
you build that resilience
yeah i think it's um it's probably one
of the most common interview questions i
guess like people in general who are
joining recruitment is like do you have
perseverance it like and what's your
proof of that and obviously everyone
said they do but i think at the end of
the day it's
actually having it
and being able to to get past those days
um
but yeah
i wouldn't say anything specific you've
just gotta let it out i think the worst
thing that i did
that i like i bottled it up and i
bottled it up a lot
yeah that was that was the worst thing
you can do and i
i'd have those bad days and i wouldn't
speak to my manager about it i wouldn't
like tell anyone so imagine all those
like small days they all build up and
then i hit this like huge super low
and i'm like oh i'm miserable like i
want to leave but it's my own fault
because i've just bottled it all up and
i haven't allowed anyone to help me so i
think the best thing to do and like when
i started actually speaking to my
manager and every time i felt like this
literally it's just like a release you
like you let it all go and you're like
okay cool i've spoken about it put it in
the past and then we carry on and like
we keep moving so i think like the
easiest way to get if you have those
issues like don't bottle it up you need
to make someone aware and you need to
allow someone to help you and that's the
only way i really got through
that that's one of the main things i can
pinpoint from the start that has changed
and has made like a really big impact is
not bottling things up if you have an
issue just speak to someone about it
yeah that's brilliant why do you think
you bottled it up
i think it's
i think because as i said when i started
i didn't know anything about recruitment
or anything about technology i didn't
want to come across like i haven't
learned anything i still don't know
anything and it's like one of our
favorite sayings as well we have a few
favorite sayings but like always assume
with positive intent and i don't think i
did that at the start i i think i felt
every time someone was giving me advice
or
um you know telling me i'm doing
something like not wrong per se but you
know the things that you can interpret
as being negative things but actually
they're giving you advice to help you
and i think i interpreted quite a lot of
it
not with positive intent so i'd get in
my own head about it
so i think um yeah no it's really
important to keep that positive mindset
no thank you for sharing that hannah i
was hoping you'd say that
because i think that is what that's what
that's what holds people that that
you're completely right people don't
want to look stupid and people don't
want to feel like like you said
like
oh i'm is this going to come across like
i'm not learning should i be
doing this more right than i i don't
know should these things be happening to
me right now so i'm glad you said that
so that that's awesome that you work
with i love that i sort of always assume
like things that come with positive
intent i really like that
so i guess just just to sort of
finish up talking about this then what
might be a good thing to ask you and i
have like asking this question recently
is like with where you're at on your
journey now if like [ __ ] hits the fan
we're talking like you have
free dropouts
uh in a week or like you just have one
of those days
like what obviously but you said like
you won't let things build up and like
you'll speak about them but like what's
your like go-to ritual or your rituals
to like deal with
the [ __ ] that recruiters have to deal
with have you got sort of a ritual that
you go to now you're writing stuff down
you're going for a walk
go home have a glass of wine
i think i think one of the nicest things
about recruitment is
even though you're working like by
yourself and you've got your own desk
technically like you are still part of a
team and everyone else goes through the
same thing like literally like going for
a drink after work and just chatting to
everyone about like letting out people
understand what a nightmare is and then
hearing their stories about when things
have gone 100 times worse than that it's
so it's like reassuring to know that you
know this isn't the end of the world
this isn't like the worst thing that's
ever happened um i wouldn't say anything
i do in particular i have a few times i
have done i guess like a bit of a
huge desk dive like i've had weeks where
i've lost out on like 30 000 pounds of
deals like in a week and it's been tough
and i'm like ah why hasn't this gone
through like what am i doing wrong and
then it's i sit down with my director i
think we sat in a room for like two
hours we went through everything that
i'm doing from start to finish and i was
like okay i'm not following processes
correctly i'm not do like i always do
this and i haven't done this part of the
process so
it's actually good to like reflect and
i think you you assume you're doing
everything and you're like oh i'm
experienced now so i know what i'm doing
but actually when you sit down and look
at it there's probably areas that you've
forgotten about or you've missed out a
bit so
just looking back through and realizing
right these are the things that i need
to make sure i'm doing every time
and
i think sometimes like i think
just taking a step back because i think
i'm like oh i know what a good cv looks
like so i'm not gonna call this person
but then
i should just be calling everyone or
there's
i think you get a little bit complacent
and a little bit cocky
so
yeah just taking it back to basics i
think is the best thing to do if there's
if you're stuck in a rut take it back to
basics start fresh recap yourself on
absolutely everything and then you can
basically like and then go home have a
glass of wine and then go again yeah i
love that now what you're talking about
there's responsibility accountability
being
willing to look at yourself in the
mirror and go what could have done
better rather than
you can easily always point at someone
uh candidate client whatever as to like
why that's happened right yeah and then
there you're going to really limit the
opportunity to grow so totally get that
that's awesome so what what did you
learn in those first six to 12 months
that you wish you knew from the
beginning
that you wish you knew from day one do
you think
yeah
i think as i kind of said before just
remembering that everyone's human like
if somebody's rude to you on the phone
like something really bad could have
just happened to them that they're not
angry at you like people have good days
people have bad days you can't take
things to heart
i think it's really important to
remember like at the end of the day just
because someone's a ceo of like a huge
company like the cto of like huge
company they're also still a human being
you don't have to be terrified to speak
to them
like i think it's just just remembering
that people are people
um
what else that's great that's great yeah
yeah
so it's quite hard to to think back
because
recruitment it like it goes so quickly
as well so it's hard to pinpoint like
when what actually was in in that like
beginning
six months
a great point i think that'll help a lot
of people to really sort of draw that
into themselves
um i guess obviously for yourself
obviously you're in the correct room if
i'm wrong here but from when we spoke
you're entirely focused on the delivery
building relationships with candidates
and the candidate process right
yeah i've gone through
i've been
mainly focused on the delivery side but
i've gone through phases where i've been
trying to get more into the bd360 side
um i did actually try to kind of move
over into the 360 role back in september
but i was in like one of my ruts where i
hadn't kind of released everything and i
was putting too much pressure on myself
not speaking with my manager
and communicating things i just put
myself in like a completely worse
headspace as well so i decided to kind
of leave that 360 side of it while i got
myself back in like out of the funk back
into the groove thing and now i'm kind
of trying to focus on focus on it a
little bit more now but yeah
predominantly as um it's all been on the
delivery yeah the reason the reason why
i brought that was i sort of had quite a
few people ask me this a lot of people
obviously start their journey depending
on the type of business they join
like i've started my journey on the
candidate side and then you sort of get
exposed to different things and uh but
like i wanted to ask you how
again with where you're at right now
what do you think has been the most
effective way for you so far to build
like sustainable relations with
candidates do you think
i think just being honest like being
personable like speaking to them
like if they know stuff about you
they're going to feel automatically like
closer to you as well and
see you as a human being not someone
who's there just trying to make money
off of them because that's not even like
a lot of the time that's not actually
the case as well obviously that's our
job but
just being a person like listening to
them having like a general conversation
and i think that's like a huge part of
it because some people obviously don't
kind of go into that like relationship
building stage um
but for me it's just a transparency like
actually trying to help them as much as
possible like our process is super
strict and i always like i'll always
make sure i send out um like really
detailed interview prep and you know
just building the relationship at every
single stage making sure you're like
having video calls with candidates as
well it's
you speak to you can speak someone on
the phone 10 times you can have a video
call with someone once and you've
already built more of a relationship
then you have like the 10 phone calls
that you've made it's just like little
things just trying to humanize there
because it is
like again they're humans
it's their job like you've gotta
actually really listen to them and
understand what they want and what's
important for them so
yeah i think just gotta relate to them
and
make sure that they realize you actually
genuinely
are interested
yeah what i take from that is yeah being
authentic like
yeah connecting with people
someone like bringing yourself to that
not like putting on this sort of
professional
mask
and then what you're talking about is
yeah it's candidate experience and
really delivering that and delivering
value
so obviously you've spoken a lot about
funk's challenging times like talk to me
about what's been one of your best or
most memorable days so far
oh god there's did we have a week where
we did 30k worth of deals did that
happen where it actually went in or
what's been your best day so far or best
week or
i think like it was probably last august
it was when i just started i guess kind
of doing the full process by myself
without any help from my manager so like
from the start to the finish um
and actually got something for the
process and i was like oh like this is
awesome like i i i know what i'm doing
like i don't need well i don't need help
anymore obviously i'm still a trainee
but
like where you feel confident and
comfortable doing that and then i think
it was like that month i ended up having
it was almost 50k months and like my
fourth
or fifth month which i i think was so
cool and it was just going home every
day i think it's really funny because
then you're like you're talking up the
commission you're making and you're like
oh yeah oh my god yeah yeah like super
super exciting um i quite funny week a
few weeks ago uh
everything was literally going to [ __ ]
basically like
it was
i i had like offers out and then the
client was like no we're actually going
to retract these offers and i was like
are you joking they're like yeah we
might be pulling all the rolls and i was
like i've literally got all these people
out final like this could be a really
good week or it could be a really bad
week and i was like every day like
what's going on what's going on what was
going on and then it was like 4 p.m on a
friday and the client called me and they
were like
nope but still going ahead with all
these roles and i was like
wow it was like this you know so nervous
and like so on the edge for like the
whole week and i was like it's gonna be
really good it's gonna be really bad and
i'm gonna have to tell this candidate
that you're not actually having this
offer anymore they've just turned down
three other roles but you're not having
this anymore i was like terrified and
it's like that i think that relief
is like a lot better than like the
excitement as well
when things don't go bad
that's basically a huge success
yeah yeah fair enough what would we do
any did we make any uh
flexes with a big commission did we make
any uh rogue purchases
with your first big commission paycheck
um
with my first one i don't know what what
did i get from my first one i kind of
said probably like botox or something
um
i don't know i had a really really big
one recently and i'm just like i need to
pay off my council tax
yeah that's that that's definitely more
annoying about that okay so
what so curious to get your thoughts on
this um yeah
like this is i guess more for people
that will be listening to this that want
to get into recruitment or interested to
it obviously there's so many recruitment
companies in in the uk
so i had a really interesting question
that someone wanted me to ask people so
um i wanted to get your thoughts on it
so basically the question is if you
could pick one thing
about the environment you joined that
has allowed you to succeed so far what
would it be
for example could be the culture
training incentives like yeah what comes
up for you yeah
i think 100 the training i had like it
was it wasn't intense but i know like
learning from someone who knows what
they're doing and knowing from someone
who's like an expert in their field like
i was really lucky i got trained by one
of our like our directors at the time
who basically like literally took me
under their wing and taught me
absolutely everything and i
to this day i credit my success to to
him but he he he's always like no hannah
it wasn't me it was you so i like back
and forth but i think that
having the
really really good training that i had
and that one-on-one time i think is
super super important as well um
you know if you're looking for a
recruitment company i'd make sure that
you're asking questions around like the
resources they have to train you like
what
what does their diary look like are they
in meetings from nine to five at least
your mandate meetings from nine to five
every day are they training like 20
other people at the same time like do
you actually have
that much time to
be trained by someone and like have
someone to learn from i mean we sat on
the desk next to each other it was like
constantly like
what's this what's that what's that
constantly asking questions and having
that really super close support around
you i think is the most important thing
and that's that's what i credit my
success to with my training
yeah that's that's great thanks for
sharing that so what we've trained in
the mind then what what's what's the
best
sort of uh training advice or yeah
advice that you got given in that sort
of training context that you received
that
really sort of helped you and really
worked and really sort of yeah ended up
playing out in a positive way in your
role you think
yeah trying to think back to my training
week seems like a lifetime ago actually
it's great you said you you said you
credit him so what are some of the
things that
you'd like yeah like he like told you
like you know what this has already
worked for me blah blah blah like you
know you even still do it now
i think you've got
to
think if you actually like if you've got
a question you've got to think whether
you actually know the answer already
because i feel like a lot of the time i
was being like doubting myself like
asking questions and one of the best
things
that um
that he did at the time was like
well what do you think the answer is and
that's and then you're like oh i
actually do know the answer like why am
i asking questions like you
i don't think you should doubt yourself
i think it's so much better to be in a
position where
you know you're giving it a go or you're
thinking about you probably know it
already and i feel like you're just kind
of
not giving yourself enough credit or
confidence if you're you know doubting
yourself in that sense um
yeah
but
i kind of think like what other
i think it was more oh okay so one of my
favorite things as well was just do it
just do it just to do it because i'm the
queen of
saying i'm gonna do it and not doing it
so then we got to this point where we
were like hannah you just need to do it
and i was like i just need to do it
like don't make excuses don't be like oh
i can't do it because of this because of
that like just do it and it's not even
going to be as bad as you thought it
would be it's not that terrifying and
the more you put it off the more scared
you're going to be the more you work
yourself up the more you waste your time
being like feeling negative or like
scared you just do it and then you're
like oh wow that was amazing that felt
great yeah like it really isn't that bad
like just do it get on the phones
whatever you're scared of doing just do
it you'll prove you'll prove yourself so
quickly that you can do it so easily as
well
yeah awesome so let let's end on this
then obviously you from what i can see
you graduated union in 2020
a lot of young people enter the the
recruitment industry a lot of people
find this podcast and it helps them
understand if it's a career for them
we've spoken about the challenges
there's been plenty of lows
but you've uh you've uh rode through
that you've worked through it and
can tell see sort of how energized you
are and
obviously whenever we suppose you seem
super happy and engaged so like
hopefully this can showcase people like
yes it is difficult yes it is
challenging but the sort of hard times
and the people you're doing it with and
the actual job itself overall in the
long term
it's all worth it but like why do you
think
more young people why do you think more
people should actually consider
recruitment as a career choice a lot of
people fall into it as an accident have
no [ __ ] clue about it but like why
should people actually identify as a
career that they want to get into from
from your perspective
yeah i think it's really funny because
i'd only had started hearing about
recruitment while i was at uni and i
this is really bad but i i remember
speaking to one of my friends and i was
like oh my god i'd never go into
recruitment like it's such a like
scapegoat of a career
and like
like a scapegoat of crayola i thought
like oh you can't get a job after you
need to go into recruitment like that is
really bad like that was my that was
like my mentality of it while i was at
uni and then i
like i basically just like started
eating my words i got into recruiting my
friend was like hannah do you remember
what you said i was like yeah i do yeah
yeah this is really where i was like but
when you like when you actually find out
more about it and realize that it's
actually quite difficult like it's not
it's not this like easy thing that you
just do and i didn't even know how much
money you could make at the time like
while i was in union i just thought
people were like i didn't even know what
recruitment was i was like oh everyone
seems to be going into that recruitment
thing like
like what even is it no one knows about
it um but i think one of the best things
just do your research find out if it is
something that you enjoy like people
obviously that they ask you if you like
a challenge like
it do you genuinely like a challenge or
will you like fall up the first hurdle
you have a bad day and then you'll be
like oh okay i'll quit then like i think
it's just actually
it's like the standard bullet points i
think that
companies in general put on a job spec
like do you like a challenge like do you
have perseverance are you can like can
you power through
but it's
actually taking note of those and
actually thinking about whether you can
and you can do it but
the money is worth it the money is worth
it and
you're working with like-minded people
around the same age like it's so much
fun it's so much fun you'll earn so much
money just like especially just coming
out of uni like you're probably not
going to find another job where you'll
be paid as much as you are um
and it like there's so many different
routes you can go down as well so much
you can learn
i feel like
a half expert in techy things which i
never thought i would be i thought i
would be like a party planner now but
obviously i'm not i'm like working in
tech recruitment which is crazy but
yeah nice um
definitely just like do research into
recruitment and
it's easy to get into it but you're the
one who's got to do the hard work to
make it work and make yourself a success
love it hannah thanks so much for
joining me uh kudos to you for getting
through the low times the challenging
times obviously excited to see how your
tech recruitment career continues to
unfold but yeah thank you so much for uh
joining me
thank you so much for having me it's
been fun